你好 你好
Hello, hello
So I would like to say...
所以我想说...
Anything happens?
发生什么事了?
آہ کھائی کھائی
* * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * * *
we would do a separate
我们会做一个单独的
Thank you.
谢谢
Yeah, I know, I know.
我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,我知道,
so
so so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so,
What if you have a...
如果你有一个...
You have a girlfriend.
你有一个女朋友。
Okay?
好吗?
Okay
好
That's pretty good
相当不错
That's pretty good.
这是相当不错的。
Know some of you match
认识你们中一些相配的人
Listen to music.
听音乐
Vou clicar em...
闪闪发光...
Okay, okay.
好,好,好。 好,好。 好,好。
That's pretty good.
这是相当不错的。
こんにちは
_____________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________________
本当に?
什么?
Håll den där ska.
Okay, the translation is pretty good.
好吧,翻译工作相当不错
So, uh...
那么 呃... So, uh...
There are some things I like to eat.
有些东西我喜欢吃
the morning I like to eat some
早晨,我喜欢吃
All orc.
全部半兽人
milk or sandwiches. Okay, so after that I will drink some coffee plus some cream.
好吧 之后我再喝咖啡加奶油
Okay, if you know that.
好吧,如果你知道这一点。
I would like to eat some steak.
我想吃点牛排
You know what?
你知道吗?
Okay.
好吧。 好吧。 好吧。 Okay.
That runs very smooth. I like it.
运行很顺利,我喜欢